as coronavirus re-emerges the media and
Democrats blame Republicans cultural
icons move to appease the wolf left and
Chazz meets its untimely demise i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your online activity should
not be pala protect yourself at
expressvpn calm /ban whoa I don't get to
everything covered relate in just a
moment first I don't announce a piece of
actual good news like I actually think
this is very good news so NASCAR
released a photo of the news that wasn't
a news in Bubba Wallace's garage and it
looks like a news it does I mean there's
that there's a picture and I am NOT an
expert on Knots in any way if I had seen
this I would have thought this looks
like a news I would have um I don't know
why NASCAR didn't release it in the
first place
the FBI did a full investigation
apparently they found that this was the
only hand tied pulldown rope and like
all of a NASCAR that looked like this so
to be immediately suspicious of this
would not have been wrong for NASCAR to
be suspicious wouldn't be wrong for
Bubba Wallace to be suspicious that this
wouldn't been wrong so I'm very glad
about that because honestly race hoaxes
are really bad people just making
mistakes that's like normal human life
and that's fine and that's good it means
that everybody went into this with good
intentions and it's coming out with good
intentions and I prefer that story a lot
more than some sort of nefarious race
hoax happened here in order to gin up
outrage or anything like that NASCAR
should have gone through the full
investigation before they ran with the
story obviously but at least when it
comes to Bubba Wallace Bubba Wallace
seems like he was acting in good faith
throughout and that's really good and so
any implication to the contrary I
apologize for if that implication was
made because now the photos out the
photos out you can see why Bubba Wallace
thought that this thing looked in his
words like a straight up news I totally
get it so that is it that's good news
again better better intentions on
everybody's part is a very good thing I
think right I mean good intentions is
better than bad intentions just as I
said that bum wall should be happy as he
said yesterday he was that this wasn't a
hate crime I am very happy that nobody
was trying to put anything over on
anybody just a good faith mistake like
that that that's a much better story for
the country all the way around okay so
meanwhile coronavirus is researching
across the United States also in Europe
so people are neglecting that it's
researching in Europe the reason they're
neglecting that it's researching in
Europe is because there's a narrative
the media have to push there
the media are pushing in the United
States is that it's only happening in
red states it is not happening in blue
states now on its face that is simply
not true
it is researching very very strongly in
California right now LA county is
apparently now the county with the most
coronavirus cases in America it's
researching in states like Washington
State which is a students where it
started in terms of the Chinese strain
of the virus New York was European
strain of the virus meaning had passed
from China to Europe and then finally on
to New York so it's just any accurate to
suggest it's only red states that are
experiencing this but the media's new
game is to pretend that blue state
governors have been doing an amazing job
with this and red state governors have
been doing a terrible job with this
we'll get to that in a second it isn't
really true but one of the big problems
that narrative is that this thing is
researching all over the world it's not
just researching in the United States
it's researching in Europe as well
according to the BBC in eleven places
including Armenia Sweden Moldova and
North Macedonia accelerated transmission
has led to a very significant resurgence
said regional director dr. Hans Henrique
Lu his warnings about the risk of her
surgeons had become reality he said if
left unchecked human Health System would
be pushed to the brink again more than
2.6 million cases of kovat 19 and
195,000 deaths have been reported in the
wh o--'s european region which is
expansive hovering 54 countries and
seven territories across Europe the
Middle East and Central Asia almost
20,000 new cases more than 700 new
deaths are being recorded daily those
those numbers look very much like the
United States as numbers frankly not in
terms of the number of cases being
identified by the number of deaths they
were accorded daily that looks very much
like the United States across the who's
the who's European region and the
population of the United States broad
scale in terms of number of people looks
very much like Europe so this idea that
the United States is being vastly
outplayed by Europe it's just not true
again the WHI European region is seen
195 thousand deaths we've seen about
120,000 deaths here in the United States
all this is horrifying of course in
several countries across Europe the risk
has now become a reality
30 countries have seen increases in new
cumulative cases over the past two weeks
and 11 of those countries accelerated
transmission has led to very significant
resurgence that if left unchecked or
push health systems to the brink once
again said the w-h-o dr. Klug said the
countries like Poland Germany Spain in
Israel had responded quickly to
dangerous outbreaks associated with
schools coal mines in food production
settings and brought them under control
through rapid interventions
he said the whu-oh anticipates that the
situation will come down further in
majority of the countries over the
summer but in the fall when covin 19 may
meet seasonal influenza pneumonia and
other diseases because ultimately the
virus is still actively circulating
there's no effective treatment no
vaccine yet we have to prepare for the
fall and this has led to enormous
repercussions in the United States and
worldwide about what happens when kids
go back to school
various regions of the United States are
treating this differently for example
there has been talking Massachusetts
about reopening with full course load in
Fairfax Virginia however in Fairfax
Virginia that county has already
announced that they're only gonna go two
days per week of school I know that in
my child's school what they've been
talking about is all the kids coming
back but the kids being forced to sit at
little cubicles and have and not eat
lunch together and they're supposed to
be taking their food from different sort
of little cubby holes and their work
from different copy holes so they're not
sharing any of the pens any of the
erasers any of the markers and all this
honestly they're children I don't
understand how that's gonna work like I
think it's gonna be very very difficult
for that to be workable I think there
may be serious questions to be asked
about whether reopening the school is
even possible if Kovan 19 continues to
be resurgent this way now there's some
good news about kovat 19 and that is the
CDC says the köppen 19 cases in the US
may be 10 times higher than reported the
estimate comes from a nationwide look at
antibody tests now why is that good news
well the reason that's good news is
because if not that many people are
dying but tons of people are infected
that means the infection fatality rate
of this thing is a lot lower than
originally supposed to remember
originally the infection fatality rate
was calculated by the w-h-o at like 3.5
percent meaning out of a hundred people
through 2.5 died and then the CDC last
month announced that they thought the
actual infection fatality rate was 0.26
meaning that out of every 10,000 people
26 people died which is a lot a lot
lower rate a lot lower and then they are
now suggesting and maybe for every case
that's reported there are actually 10
other infections which would mean that
it's quite possible that the actual
infection fatality rate looks more like
the flu it's just way way more
transmissible Buffalo the flu has a
reproduction rate of a little below 2 as
my understanding the reproduction rate
on this virus if left unchecked is well
above 3 so that means like if everybody
in the country got the flu more people
will die of the flu even if the flu were
just the flu well it's possible that's
actually what we're seeing right here it
does hit different populations in
different ways by the way obviously for
young people it is significantly less
deadly than the flu if you're under the
age of 25 by all statistics it's less
deadly than the flu if you're over the
age of 25 it's a multiple of how deadly
the flu is depending on again how many
outstanding untested cases you believe
there are according to NBC News the
assessment comes from looking at blood
samples across the country for the
presence of antibodies to the virus for
every confirmed case of Cova 19 10 more
people had antibodies Redfield said
referring to proteins in the blood that
indicate whether a person's immune
system has previously fought off the
corona virus the samples aren't just
from people who have had antibody
testing they also come from testing
performed on donated blood at blood bags
or from other other laboratory testing a
blood currently there are two point
three million covered 19 cases reported
in the United States the CDC's it new
estimate pushes the actual number of
corona virus cases up to at least 23
million so there's good news and there's
bad news the good news is that if you
get it and it turns out that lots of
people are asymptomatic then that means
that maybe the chances aren't that great
that you died which is fantastic news
right you get it's not a death sentence
on the other hand if it's really
transmissible that means that there's a
better chance that you are going to get
it and experience that risk in your life
Redfield said the virus causes so much
asymptomatic infection the traditional
approach of looking for symptomatic
illness and diagnosing it obviously
underestimates the total number of
infections on Thursday the CDC expanded
its list of who is a great greatest risk
for coveted 19 complications removing
the age cutoff of 65 dr. Jay Butler the
head of the Cova 19 response at the CDC
said there's not an exact cutoff of age
at which people should or should not be
concerned he said rather a person's risk
increases with age but that does not
preclude younger adults from
complications indeed people of any age
with underlying health conditions have a
higher risk obviously CDC also clarified
other conditions that might increase a
person's risk of severe illness that
includes the asthma high blood pressure
neurologic conditions like dementia
cerebrovascular disease such as stroke
and pregnancy the CDC is incentivized by
the way to be extremely careful about
this sort of stuff so that means that if
you have high blood pressure it's not
gonna be quite as deadly as if you have
what type-2 diabetes or something so
lumping it all together is a little bit
inaccurate but the bottom line is that
when you look at the the rate of death
from the behavior that is the the
rates of death from behavior may be a
lot lower than originally suspected that
does not mean that the danger is gone
obviously or that the virus is not
dangerous obviously and again we still
don't know how many people are
asymptomatic very difficult to test for
people for asymptomatic except with sort
of broad scale antibody testing and we
still don't know by the way if the
antibodies are truly productive which is
a serious problem right I mean if you
get the antibodies it's not necessarily
guaranteed there's not going to be a
secondary infection people get the flu
every year and then the next year they
get the flu again so there's still a lot
of open questions about all of this now
we're gonna get to the political side of
this which is really stupid and really
ugly but that's our time stupid and ugly
I'll get to that in just a moment first
let's talk about how important it is to
feel safe in your own home I need to
feel safe in my home not only because
I'm a public figure but I got a lot of
little kids running around my property
and that means I want to know what's
going on on my property at my front door
at my front gate all the time and that
means I need ring we're home a lot more
than usual these days it's still hard to
keep a close eye on things that means
that there are more deliveries that
means more boxes left unattended more
opportunities for people to steal
packages from your mail my friends Dave
Rubin actually was able to help the
police after somebody stole packages
from his mail because he has ring-ring
is on a mission to make neighborhood
safer their home and security products
are designed to give you peace of mind
around the clock from video doorbells
and security cameras to smart security
lighting and alarm systems ring has
everything you need to make sure your
family and belongings are safe and
secure anytime anywhere and with the all
new ring video doorbell three you can
keep an even even closer eye on things
than ever before ring gives you
protection at every corner video
doorbells will let you answer the door
and check in on your home anytime keep
an eye on your doorstep speech delivery
people when you can't come to the door
get a special offer on the ring welcome
kit today when you go to ring.com
slash then the Welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell 3 and the chime Pro
that's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today just
go to ring comm slash pen again that's
ring.com slash man go check them out
right now at ring.com
slash then hey so here's where it gets
really really stupid
media have decided they're really gonna
cover in large scale only Texas Florida
Arizona California just is not gonna get
the same kind of coverage so California
which again is experiencing a massive
resurgence of Kovan 19 right now and
California which was locked down heavily
it still is locked down heavily like you
can't go to a restaurant in California
right now if you if you try to go to a
restaurant in California they'd be
we just reopened in the last couple of
weeks many many restaurants still have
not fully reopened because they can't
actually fulfill all of the basic
prerequisites for reopening major
businesses are still not open in places
like Los Angeles Los Angeles been very
slow to come around on this thing hey
over the past few weeks really since the
protests you started to see LA open up a
lot more in California open up a lot
more and it is perfectly obvious that
everybody was basically abiding by the
stay at home orders until these massive
protests broke out and the entire media
infrastructure decided that you were
immune to kovat if you went out to a
major protest and then precisely two
weeks later exactly is everybody
suspected you started to see this
massive uptick in places like California
now everyone wanted to blame that on
Memorial Day but Memorial Day happened
May 25th protests started May 26th so
it's really really difficult to suggest
that it was just Memorial Day and not
you know the obvious problem of hundreds
of thousands of people out in the
streets in America's major cities so
California has been really hard hit in
this resurgence there are states like
like Idaho that I've been very hard hit
in the resurgence Washington state which
as I say it was a starter state for this
thing has been very hard hit in the
resurgence but the media have decided
they are only going to cover Abbott in
two Santa's but they're gonna cover Greg
Abbott in in Texas Texas has now paused
reopening as hospitals have been
inundated with quote an explosion of
kovat at 19 cases officials in Texas
yesterday reported 47 more deaths nearly
six thousand infections a quote-unquote
grim at new daily record now worth
noting New York State yesterday still
recorded I believe more deaths than that
so New York is supposed to be in the
downswing of this thing and they are but
even in their downswing they're
recording more deaths on a daily basis
then I believe either texas or Florida
if not more than absolutely in the same
ballpark the governor of Texas hit the
brakes on reopening his state Thursday
as hospitals were inundated with an
explosion of cover 19 cases according to
NBC News the last thing we wanted to as
the state is go backwards and close down
businesses governor Greg Abbott said in
a statement his temporary pause will
help our state Corral the spread until
we can safely enter the next phase of
opening our state for business Abbott
urged all Texans to do their parts that
slowed the spread of Cova 19 by wearing
a mask washing their hands regularly
socially distancing from others he said
the more we all follow these guidelines
the safer our state will be the more we
can open up Texas for business now that
makes perfect sense again I've been
saying for a long time if you want the
economy
to be reopen then put on a mask
seriously slow the spread of the thing
make sure the elderly aren't paying help
the the question is what good policy
looks like here good wait here's what
good policy looks like to me and I've
been saying this literally for months
protect the elderly and the vulnerable
particularly the nursing homes or a
disproportionate number of deaths have
taken place wear a mask if you are in a
public place where this thing is easily
transmitted and socially distance if you
can that's pretty much all you can do
those are all the things there are no
more things than that you know and limit
giant public gatherings obviously
because giant public gatherings where
these things spread and where people
tend to take off the masks and wear
battle with masks don't reduce risk to
zero if you're wearing a surgical mask
you might reduce the risk by 30 40
percent as dr. Marty Meharry from from
Johns Hopkins University said but you're
not gonna reduce the risk by 100 percent
but a lot of people reducing it by 30 40
percent is definitely a good thing Texas
Medical Center in Houston has reported
all the ties to you beds are now
occupied so Houston has been
particularly hard-hit the United States
saw a record number of new corona virus
cases in a single day forty five
thousand five hundred fifty-seven
reported on Wednesday according to Itali
by NBC News southern and western states
like Arizona in Florida that began
aggressively reopening around Memorial
Day are now seeing staggering spikes
that make clear the deadly virus is
showing no signs of going away now this
is where the media's coverage bias
starts to come in okay the reality is a
lot of these states started opening
before Memorial Day a lot of these
states started opening like mid-may and
they didn't see a spike in fact
everybody was sort of puzzled why don't
we sing a spike and the answer was that
people were going about their business
but they were being responsible and how
they went about their business in fact
I'm gonna look it up right now when did
when did Florida reopening flow I won't
actually see the calendar so the
original the original reopening let's
see Florida reopen certain businesses
through much of the state May 4th May
4th right starting May 4th restaurants
were allowed to offer outdoor seating
with six-foot spaces between so they
started their reopening May 4th nothing
from nothing for month then massive
protests suddenly resurgence don't tell
me it was Memorial Day can when you
start reopening at the beginning of May
and there are other states that did this
to track Georgia started reopening
beginning of May no massive resurgence
giant protests
massive resurgence they're gonna try and
put it on the reopening as opposed to
like people who are attending
restaurants and sitting six feet apart
from each other as opposed to you know
giant protests where people are up on
each other yelling and spitting and by
the way the elegant spitting isn't is
athe thing here right one of the chief
vectors of the spread of Koba 19 is
projection this is why churches have
been in place where people are getting
very sick because if you go to a church
and everybody is singing together when
you sing and you aerosolize a lot of the
particles in your body while your spit
and then it goes in the air and then
lots of people can get infected but
again the media are focusing only in on
Florida and Arizona the turning blame
Republicans for this is the bottom line
buried way down in the article is
California which was among the first to
put in place a statewide law town has
also been reporting record numbers of
new cases many of them young people and
there was no evidence yet that the black
lives matter protest that swept the
nation after the police killing of
George Floyd or fueling the sunrise
because you're gonna have to explain why
California which has been completely
locked down but allowed massive protests
is also seeing a significant spike where
was the other giant public activity it
did not exist I'm from LA no one was
going out of their house then la was
locked down during curfew and then
shockingly the cases rise Health and
Human Services Secretary Alex azar said
it's important for the American people
to know this is a localized
situation it's not everywhere rights in
certain places particularly Scott
Gottlieb former FDA Commissioner he said
we opened we reopened against the
backdrop of a lot of persistent spread
in those states it's inevitable the
cases were gonna go up I think they've
gone up more than most people expected
I've certainly been surprised by the
acceleration in the cases as well I
think most of us were in Texas dr. fasal
Massoud the medical director of critical
care medicine at Houston Methodist
Hospital system said they were managing
for now but quote if this trajectory is
what was the last 10 days when we
literally had a tripling of our cases we
can't do that for a couple of weeks at
all he said this isn't good the
explosion of patients all across that
explosion has to slow down one of the
things that's happening is people are
assuming that all the ICU beds are
available for kovat 19 cover 19
represents about a quarter of the of the
number of people who are in the ICU
people are in the ICU for a number of
like you have a heart attack here in the
ICU you don't have cover 19 meanwhile in
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo insisted
he was serious about enforcing a
two-week quarantine he and governors of
New Jersey and Connecticut want all
visitors from current coronavirus
hotspot states like Texas
Florida and Alabama to follow and this
is where we get into the real hardcore
media bias okay so we're in a second
we're gonna hear the Washington Post try
to blame Sean Hannity for the uptick in
cover 19 and we're also gonna hear the
media try and tout governor's Andrew
Cuomo and Gretchen Whitmer of Michigan's
who have the worst governor's in America
if you are a governor they're really
only a few things you can do one is bar
large gatherings two is you can have a
statewide mask mandate but it's very
difficult to enforce basically you rely
on the compliance of the American people
that's all you can really do and three
is you protect your nursing homes
whitmer and Cuomo both shipped old
people with cover 19 back into nursing
homes and they killed like a huge
percentage of the old people in nursing
homes in their state and they're being
touted by the media because because
there is now a time delay between when
we watched New York get walloped and
Michigan get walloped and now now we're
supposed to believe that they were great
at this I did an amazing amazing job
because after we lost what 25,000 people
in New York City something along those
lines after we lost tens of thousands of
people in New York City because Governor
Cuomo and Bill DeBlasio are terrible at
their jobs now they're good at their
jobs because they're on the other side
of the decline yeah you killed off
everybody who's vulnerable turns out
that the spread isn't this grave in New
York as you thought by the way my
prediction in the next couple of weeks
because of the protests you will in fact
see a spike in cases in New York as well
I don't think there's gonna be
restricted to places like Florida or or
California we'll get to more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that well you're on pandemic
living it is very easy to put on weight
it really is like you're sitting home
you can't go to the gym it's really
really rough so how have I become so
stumped during the pandemic I have been
using a new
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale it's
about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into that favorite pair of jeans did
your goal terrific but there are many
reasons you might want to practice
self-care every person is different this
is why you should have neumes your
habits that's the only way to truly lose
weight the truth is lots of different
diets work lots of different exercise
regimens work the one thing that is at
the predicate for all of them is being
very meticulous and how you change your
habits regarding health and exercise
Noom is they have a changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship of food than personalised
courses
based in psychology Noom teaches you why
you do the things you do it empowers you
with the tools you need to break bad
habits and replace them with better ones
Noom doesn't tell you what to do and
what not to do it teaches you how to
look inside your own mind and make
better decisions for yourself chat with
your goal specialist at noon community
to get and give help to people going
through the same things enough to change
it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon and om
accom / Shapiro yeah nothing to lose
except the way visit new Montcalm /
Shapiro to start that trial today that's
N oom calm / Shapiro okay so the media
are now trying to turn this on
Republicans it's all Republicans fault
you guys are gaslighting us you're
gaslighting us you spent weeks
explaining that going out and protesting
in the streets was fully justified
because racism was more dangerous than
Kovan now kovat is spreading across the
country unchecked and you're like oh
it's the Republicans fault by the way
this is why it was political malpractice
for the President of the United States
to start holding into our rallies he
should have immediately said listen I'm
taking this seriously look who's not
taking this seriously everything that
happens from here on in that's on the
Democrats who said it was okay to get
together in giant giant groups and
scream and yell there's political
malpractice not to not to have done that
frankly hey the by the so Florida and
Texas acting responsibly are slowing
down the reopening rounded Santas said
that he never said one floor would move
to the next phase
he said that South Florida is on its
laid reopening schedule most businesses
have resumed in Florida including bars
and nightclubs with the exception of the
hard-hit Miami metropolitan area but
there's still strict capacity limits and
other rules as well what I know about I
mean these things are accurate people
are not crowding into spaces people are
mostly eating outside but according to
the media again the only people to blame
here are members of the Republican Party
and or conservative members of the media
not Andrew Cuomo suggesting this was not
a big deal in early March not Bill
DeBlasio telling people to come on down
to Chinatown not Bill DeBlasio telling
people to go to theaters everything was
all fine not not Nancy Pelosi explaining
that everybody should celebrate Chinese
New Year's in downtown San Francisco
like none of that the only people to
blame ever are Republicans there's a
piece awful piece in The Washington Post
today called new research explores how
conservative media misinformation may
have intensified the severity of the
pandemic big emphasis on May big
emphasis on May in recent weeks three
studies have focused on conservative
media
role in fostering confusion about the
seriousness of the coronavirus taken
together says The Washington Post they
paint a picture of a media ecosystem
that amplifies misinformation entertains
conspiracy theories and discourage his
audiences from taking contruct concrete
steps to protect themselves and others
the end results according to one of the
studies is that infection and mortality
rates are higher in places where one
pundit who initially downplayed the
severity of the pandemic Fox News News
Sean Hannity reaches the largest
audience here the study is awful like
I've looked at the study the study is
just garbage the study basically
suggests that they puts aside all
confounds and then basically suggests
that if you watch Sean Hannity you were
more likely to go out and act in an
irresponsible way and there's very very
likely here's their final conclusion the
authors used anonymous location data
from millions of cell phones to explore
how the popularity of Fox News in a
given zip code related to social
distancing practices there by March 15
they found a 10% increase in Fox News
viewership within a zip code reduced its
residents propensity to stay home in
compliance with Public Health guidelines
by about 1.3 percentage points that's
not even close to causality do you think
that people like spend all day watching
Fox News in a County like that that's
all they do
there are no confounded factors there
the I'm sorry this is just absurd it's
plausible of course this difference in
behavior could be attributed to other
characteristics of Fox viewers such as
their age or political ideology or the
fact that they live by the way in more
rural areas where people are not as
afraid of coronavirus because they don't
think they're in a big city right there
there plenty of reasons but it seems to
me that New York Michigan New Jersey got
absolutely Wallops by this thing these
are not Sean Hannity centers of gravity
the attempt to paint this as a Sean
Hannity problem it's truly amazing and
blame it on it's all it's all Sean's
fault well what absolute horse crap what
absolute horse crap meanwhile Democrats
being played up as heroes during all
this so Chris Cuomo who's been giving
just propaganda slots to his brother
Andrew Cuomo yesterday he did this
routine praising his brother Andrew
Cuomo he is the best he's the bestest
governor he's my favorite favorite
bestest governor and he's my bro and
he's the bestest governor so Chris Cuomo
did this sickening sick of Fanta crew
teen with his brother who completely
botched the effort to contain Cove it in
his own state here is Chris Cuomo
praising
this is real news right here I hope you
are able to appreciate what you did in
your state and what it means for the
rest of the country now and what it will
always mean to those who love and care
about you the most
I'm wowed by what you did and more
importantly I'm wild by how you did it
this was very hard I know it's not over
but obviously I love you as a brother
obviously I'll never be objective
obviously I think you're the best
politician in the country but I hope you
feel good about what you did for your
people because I know they appreciate it
nothing's perfect
you'll have your critics thank but I've
never seen anything like what you did
and that's why I'm so happy to have had
you on the show
absolutely yeah so proud of you bro he's
just in the best job yeah talk to the
people whose relatives died alone in
nursing homes so I talked to those
people and then Andrew Cuomo had the
gall the Gulf
I mean unmitigated gall that I will say
the dude has has stones to say something
like this he goes on national TV and he
says that red state governor's played
politics and lost play politics and lost
let me just make this clear to date to
date New York states I mean I'm gonna
redo the statistics okay New York State
has Cova 19 deaths New York State total
kovat 19 deaths at this point let's see
about 20 4,800 Cova 19 deaths in New
York hey now I'm gonna look at Florida
Florida to date with the same population
as New York effectively 3,300 27 deaths
in New York again just so I can repeat
that slowly for those of you in the
mainstream media don't seem to
understand basic statistics New York had
a nearly 25,000 deaths from clubbin 19
Florida is still well under 4,000 deaths
Texas another horrible state right I
he'll escape for all of this Texas has
had under 2,300 deaths so far okay
Arizona right another hellscape
completely botched because a terrible
terrible Governor Doug Ducey has had
less than 1500 deaths so far but don't
worry andrew Cuomo is the real hero in
this here's Andrew Cuomo explaining that
it was the Republicans playing politics
and they lost how is it possible that
they lost when you're the one who lost
almost literally ten times the number of
people in your state with the same
population explain Andrew Cuomo
explain look at the numbers you play
politics with this virus and you lost
you told the people of your state you
told the people of this country White
House don't worry about it just open up
go about your business this is all
democratic hyperbole oh really now you
see 27 states with the numbers going up
you see the death projections going up
you see the economy going down who was
never politics it was always science and
they were in denial and denial is not a
life strategy okay they're in denial and
the denial is not a life strategy no
one's in denial except for you okay
you're the one who's shipping people
with Kovan 19 back into nursing homes
and then blaming Trump for it and
pretending that it was all about Trump
not telling you the source of the virus
was Europe not China I mean like it's
just absurd it's absurd and this guy
gets played as a person who knows what
he's doing I mean you want like clearest
case media bias ever this is clearest
case media bias ever Hey other other
example of media bias today an insane
New York Times profile of a governor
Gretchen Whitmer it's got the it's got
the photo of her looking off into the
distance this black and white photo of
her looking off into the distance from
Phil Montgomery and here's the headline
a governor on her own with everything at
stake from her living room Gretchen
Whitmer has led Michigan through a
pandemic an economic meltdown and even a
dam collapse all at a time when
government itself seems broken we're
just gonna read you the stats from
Michigan Michigan has over 6,000 deaths
Michigan has over 6,000 deaths Texas
again still has less than 2,500 Florida
still has less than 3,500 Arizona still
has less than 1,500 her state has 6,000
deaths already they lost 18 people
yesterday in Michigan and yet she's
getting the just the Royal Treatment the
absolute wonderful royal treatment in
her state I'm gonna need some evidence
as to why Gretchen Whitmer who also by
the way was shipping people back into
nursing homes with coven 19 which is
like the number one thing you do not do
why she's getting this sort of treatment
from the mainstream media other than the
media are trying to play up Democrats
some of the quotes from this thing I
mean she it's like a press it's like her
press office wrote it the New York Times
as Whitmer is not naturally
introspective recounting the almost
incomprehensible consequential decisions
she was making
daily basis she rarely lingered on how
she felt or the magnitude of the moment
she was more inclined to review events
and discuss strategy approaching it all
with the same practical mindset and
vocabulary she brought to more
manageable government challenges like
fixing potholes the effect wasn't
necessarily stirring there was no
soaring rhetoric about the need to rise
to this historic challenge but it was
hardly reassuring
she was channeling panic into process uh
what what an amazing amazing person as
the days past the decisions facing
whitmer came to seem less complicated
the next time I talked to her she'd just
returned from a march through Detroit
with a group of local religious leaders
she went with one of her two teenage
daughters who'd been pestering her for
days to let her attend a protest it was
a peculiar development a head of
government participating in a protest
against the government but it also made
perfect sense in this deeply
disorienting moment there's a lot of
pain across this country she said when I
asked what it inspired her to go to the
protest this is a righteous cause and I
wanted to be there in person in the
middle of a pandemic
well chiding other people what would it
what a heroine what a heroine I mean
just incredible stuff so I think we can
all get the picture here the picture is
very simple if you're Republican or a
bad guy if you're Democrat you're a good
guy all this does translate into some of
the national polling that we are seeing
right now amidst all of the chaos on
race which we'll get to in a moment
amidst the fact that at this pandemic
continues to to spread across the
country somewhat unabated the death
rates are significantly down but still
obviously it's a dangerous virus people
think that according to particular
estimate s-- there'll be 200 thousand
people dead by the end of summer which
obviously would be a tragedy of historic
proportions President Trump is down in
even the Fox News swing swing state
polls
according to Fox News President Trump is
down nine in Florida 4940 he's down two
in North Carolina which he won last time
47 45 he won all of these states by the
way Biden is up to in Georgia 47 45 and
Biden's up one in Texas according to the
Fox News poll okay if those polls are
anything close to accurate then the
president's got a serious problem
meanwhile Joe Biden is just basically
sleeping through this campaign I mean
really sleeping through it where's his
great leadership there's in matram it's
not about Biden's great leadership this
is almost solely about Trump's behavior
truly the American people are not
willing to undergo a pandemic without
leadership they are not willing to to
watch statues torn down and the country
riven by race riots without any sort of
leadership they're not willing to see
republics of chad set up without any
sort of presidential leadership this is
not about Biden the way he can tell us a
lot about Biden is by instilling crackin
50% in the national polling the ones
that show up like 14% it shows him that
like 50 to 36 it's not showing him in 60
to 40 it's not to him in 60 40 it's not
showing him fifty five to 40 it's
showing him at forty nine right he's
always below 50 which means that this is
not about Joe Biden it is purely about
the unpopularity of President and that
makes that makes perfect sense what Joe
Biden right now is showing us that it is
very difficult literally to beat a dead
horse that that's what that's what we're
seeing right now it is almost impossible
to beat a dead horse because that's all
he is he's just a stand-in for inanimate
object now as we were about to discuss
he actually is not an inanimate object
and that's what's dangerous well what
makes him a dangerous candidate is the
fact that how he act as president is not
going to be anything like the dead horse
that he is as a candidate and he is you
know obviously not performing as a
candidate he Boeing it's a brilliant
campaign no it's not a campaign at all
he understands that all his campaign has
to be is just there it just has to be
breathing and that's pretty much all
you're getting I mean even when he's
supposed to be speaking about things
like Hoeven he's just blowing it right I
mean he said yesterday that we have a
hundred and twenty million dead from
komen which I feel like would be bigger
news if that were true here was Joe
Biden staggering his way through another
interview but this guy's in the lead and
he's only in the lead for one reason the
feeling of chaos the feeling of
volatility and the feeling that these
things aren't getting locked down and
that Joe Biden represents some sort of
return to normal so you know as we will
see he does not represent a return to
normalcy that's what that's what makes
this election so dangerous here's Biden
people don't have a job people don't
have anywhere to go they don't know what
they're going to do and a lot of people
you have unnecessarily now we have over
120 million dead from Kovan 120 million
dead from covered Wow figured wouldn't
known about them yeah we're gonna get to
in a second why it's dangerous for this
man to become presidents of the United
States because the aunt quick quick
spoiler alert the answer is because Joe
Biden
like most members of the Democratic
Party he's beholden to his radical left
it's hard to portray him that way
because he's old and because he's
doddering and because unthreatening and
because he explicitly disassociated from
sort of the Bernie Sanders wing of the
party but he won't actively disassociate
from some of the more radical planks
people in his party want he's a weakling
in other words we're gonna get to that
in a second first right now let's talk
about the fact that anybody who runs a
business you know you gotta be on top of
your numbers right now everything so
volatile you must be granular and your
approach to your own numbers and your
own data so what you need is NetSuite by
Oracle it's the world's number one cloud
business system finance HR inventory
ecommerce everything you need all in one
place so you save time money and
headaches whether you're doing a million
or hundreds of millions in sales
NetSuite will give you the visibility
and control so you can manage every
penny with precision join over 20,000
companies who trust NetSuite to go
faster with confidence NetSuite has
surveyed hundreds of business leaders
assembled a playbook of the top
strategies they are using as America
reopens for business receive your free
guide seven actions the businesses need
to take right now schedule your free
product tour and NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro get your free guide schedule
that free product tour right now at
NetSuite comm slash up here that's
NetSuite comm slash Shapiro go check
them out right now you want to be on
again you can't afford to not be on top
of your data that's where all the
efficiency gets lost and that might be
your entire profit margin it might be
your ability to run a successful
business make sure that all your
business systems are integrated we are a
daily where you should be to go check
out and NetSuite by Oracle today receive
that free guide seven actions businesses
need to take right now schedule that
free product tour at NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro that's NetSuite comm slash
Shapiro ok so the reason that Joe Biden
remains a danger to the country despite
the fact that he's effectively senile
and not with it at this point is
specifically because he is not going to
be stymieing his left-wing base the
left-wing base is taking control the
party completely how do you know this
well over the past several days there
has been this real push this very very
hard push to tear down all the statues
right not just the statues of
Confederate generals to blow up Mount
Rushmore I mean I predicted this but
there's there's a campaign afoot to
change Mount Rushmore there's there's a
campaign afoot to get rid of the
Jefferson Memorial and there's a there's
a campaign to get rid of statues of
George Washington Nancy Pelosi is now
caving to us and Nancy Pelosi was asked
yesterday about tearing down statues and
she said well maybe we should consider
whether any statues ought to exist I
mean this is this is wild stuff these
mainstream Democratic politicians who
run the party caving to the woke base of
their party that wants to rip down
statues of the founders of the country
which again is endemic of a certain
ideology that is truly ugly about the
United States here is Nancy Pelosi
yesterday with the Washington Post these
Confederates Jefferson Davis Alexander
Stevens they committed treason against
the United States in the name of slavery
I think that's a different story
but you know what subject everything to
scrutiny and make a decision but I do
think we should do it in a safer way
rather than more dangerous what
subjected all subjected all the scrutiny
Jefferson Washington says yeah it's
different it's different for like
Jefferson Davis which of course is true
but then she's like well maybe you
should let's consider all of it Joe
Biden's campaign when I say that this is
infected the entire Democratic
infrastructure so the Daily Caller
reached out to the Biden campaign and
asked them if the former vice president
agrees with Democrats want to tear down
statues of George Washington ulysses s
grant Theodore Roosevelt and some
depictions of Jesus the campaign was
given over 24 hours to respond to the
inquiry they did not do so that is not a
shock at all of course they're not going
to do so the entire campaign of Joe
Biden is to play dead to appease his
woke base now what will he do when he's
in office so I don't think he's stupid
enough to actually attempt to tear this
sort of stuff down but I also do not
think that he is in control of his own
party and I think that the his own party
has gone so far off the rails at this
point that's being dictated to by the
likes of Nicole Hannah Jones the founder
of the 16:19 project and Nicole Hannon
that there's a hole now nationwide
discussion prompted by a bad essay by
Nicole Hannah Jones on slavery
reparations that likens the death of
Michael Brown to to lynchings from 1910
in Oklahoma and man it's an absurd piece
it's being discussed ad nauseam on
television today because the Democratic
Party has been taken over by the woken
the locusts members of their political
of their political clique by the way I
think it's important to note where
Nicole Hannah Jones is coming from so
here's the thing if you wrote something
like 25 30 years ago and then you
repudiate it you say yeah those a bad
idea that was a stupid thing to right I
get it I've done it myself and I was
writing from the time I was 17 years old
and when you write publicly you are
subjected
scrutiny as he should be I have an
entire list online of things that I have
said from the time I was young that I
regret having said and thought was
stupid or bad right that that's all
normal that's a normal thing in public
discourse so it is not outside the realm
of reality to ask about Nicole Hannah
Jones about this this letter to the
editor that she apparently wrote this
according to the Federalist reporting
today Jordan Davidson reporting over the
Federalist a letter from Nicole Hannah
Jones to the editor of the school
newspaper and Notre Dame now this
doesn't mean anybody should be canceled
I'm not saying Nicole Hannah Jones
should be canceled for she shouldn't be
canceled in fact I think it's very good
that the New York Times is just allowing
her free reign over there so we can see
that the New York Times is a trash
compost heap that it's just garbage
because frankly the 16:19 project is
garbage in and of itself enough that
like I don't need further cause to think
that Nicole Hannah Jones is very bad at
her job I've read you enough quotes of
her saying crazy things and I don't
think you need more proof that she's bad
at her job but it does go to the
question of sort of motivation and
whether she has changed her opinion on
any of this stuff because it's coming
from a lot of the same places here is
what she wrote back when she was in
college
sure I find it hard to believe that any
member of the white race can have the
audacity and hypocrisy to call any other
culture savage the white race is the
biggest murderer rapist pillager and
thief of the modern world Europeans have
colonized and destroyed the indigenous
populations on every continent of this
planet they've committed genocide
against cultures that have never
offended them in their greed and
insatiable desire to control and
dominate every non-white culture
Christopher Columbus and those like him
were no different than Hitler
the crimes that committed were
unnecessarily cruel and can be only
described as acts of the devil Africans
had been to the Americas long before
Columbus or any Europeans the difference
is that Africans had the decency and
respect for human life to learn from the
Native Americans and train technology
with them this is a weird thing the
pyramids of the Aztecs and the great
stone heads of the Olmecs are lasting
monuments to the friendship of these two
peoples that's an interesting take on
where those monuments came from but as
David Walker wrote in his appeal of 1829
the white men acted quote more like
Devils than accountable men whites have
always been an unjust at gelas
unmerciful avaricious and bloodthirsty
set of beings always seeking after power
and authority it was not enough for
whites to come to the Americas and learn
they looked upon the native people as
inferior and a people to be annihilated
that a lasting monument was the
destruction and enslavement of two races
of people using Christianity as their
excuse the white race denied the native
people their humanity
only two they rape and murder the
indigenous peoples of America they
killed off many more by introducing
diseases which came from filth and
uncleanliness to the native people poop
only existed in Europe the white race
use deceit and trickery warfare and rape
to steal the land from people who had
lived here for thousands and thousands
of years over and over again White's
made peace treaties with the Native
Americans telling them them if they
moved to just this one time and gave up
their lands the greedy settlers just
this one last time they would never have
to move again it was common knowledge
that the white man's word could not be
trusted even today the descendants of
these savage people pump drugs and guns
into the black community pack black
people into the squalor of segregated
urban ghettos and continue to be
bloodsuckers in our communities yes it
was Columbus that set the platforms for
these racist American institutions a
devil calling someone a savages like a
pot calling the kettle black but after
everything these barbaric Devils did I
do not hate them or their descendants I
understand that because of some lacking
they felt they need they needed to
constantly prove their superiority ok
the wild stuff right so here's the thing
again you shouldn't be canceled over
this because I don't think people should
be canceled over opinions generally I
think it's complete waste of time and
it's not like we didn't know that this
is the kind of stuff that she was
writing back in college because she
basically writes a watered down version
of this today it is just a very it seems
to me very important to recognize the
root ideology that is now being
promulgated in the Democratic Party at
its most crude form by the way it's not
just a nickel Hannah Jones like she's an
ideological thought leader and obviously
the de-facto editor of the New York
Times at this point but as people like
Jamelle Bouie Jamelle Bouie literally
just said the other day quote neither
Abraham Lincoln nor the Republican Party
freed the slaves
instead the slaves freed the slaves
emancipation was quote something they
took for themselves the most that can be
said of Lincoln and the nation's
political leadership is that they quote
helped set freedom in motion and
eventually codified it into law with the
Thirteenth Amendment Bowie says that the
Union Army basically only delivered the
news of the Emancipation Proclamation um
what what yes black Americans were very
important in contributing to the
abolitionist movement also hundreds of
thousands of white men died to free
black slaves Abraham Lincoln spends his
presidency working to free black slaves
abolitionism was a longtime cause in the
white community in the United States
William Lloyd
garrison I mean like this is just so
it's so ignorant on every level and
stupid on every level and divisive on
every level but you know this is this is
the new narrative the new narratives
that America is root evil and that its
root evil and and racially divided in
its entirety
that's the ideology that's taken over
the Democratic Party and it's really
really really dangerous stuff it's
really dangerous stuff and the fact that
Biden is not forcibly disavowing that
sort of ideology that does not speak to
a moderate presidency should he ever
gain power we're gonna get some more of
this in just a second the Cultural
Revolution continuing a pace we'll get
to that first everybody means a great
pair of wireless earbuds these days but
before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
wireless earbuds from Ray Khan you
already know Drake honey but start about
half the price of any other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and they
sound just as amazing as the other top
audio brands you know their newest model
the everyday eats 25-year buds are their
best ones yet six hours of playtime
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
more compact design gives you that nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are incredibly comfortable they
are perfect for conference calls or
binging podcast unlike some of your
other wireless options ray con earbuds
are stylish and discreet no dangling
wires no stems to distract anyone during
a video calls now is the time to get the
latest and greatest from recon get 15%
off your order at buy rake on Comm slash
man that is bu ir a YCL ENCOM slash man
for 15% off rake on wireless earbuds buy
rake on comm slash Ben go check them out
right now by rake on Comm slash Ben for
that 15 percent off they're really great
I mean I can tell you that they fit
perfectly in your ear in a way that a
lot of these other one-size-fits-all
your buds do not they come in a variety
of colors go check them out today by
Raycom comm / Ben for 15% off okay we're
gonna get more into the cultural
revolution in the very very sad death of
Chaz Chaz not not a person that the
place Chad's has met its untimely demise
the best story of the year I mean really
it's been a terrible year it Chaz's a
fantastic story we'll get to that in
just one second first if you've never
pre-ordered a book before make this your
very first time for your bring a book
because I think my most important book
and I I really like right side of
history I think this is a more important
book for the time this book how to
destroy America in three easy steps I
wrote back in December and January I
talked about the coming dissolution of
the country I talked about how the 69
project was destroying our history now
there was an attempt afoot by what I
call dis integrationist to divide
America along racial and class lines how
America's philosophy was being destroyed
in real time the philosophy of equal
rights before the law being discarded
how our culture of rights our belief in
things like freedom of speech the right
to bear arms all this was being
discarded you know I the book is not
just a diagnosis of our ills it is a
solution to the ills because it explains
what is so great about America in the
first place why are all these things
worthy of being upheld and why is the
argument being made by people like
Nicole Hannah Jones just so wrong both
historically as a matter of fact and
also why is it so wrong ideologically
and so dangerous for the country the
book is called how to destroy America in
three easy steps I think it's a really
really important book I didn't have any
idea how relevant was gonna be when I
wrote it turns out supremely relevant
you want to know what's happening in the
country how to fix it preorder it right
now at daily wire comm slash been to
pre-order the book is out July 21st so
you'll get it like the first few days it
is in stock when you pre-order at daily
wire.com slash Ben meanwhile it is that
glorious time of the week when I give a
shout out to a daily where I remember
today it's Megan on Instagram
understands that sometimes you have to
make tough sacrifices for your kids in
this picture Megan's son sports a
spider-man t-shirt and you're smiling
ear-to-ear proudly holding the world's
greatest beverage vessel it is indeed
fantastic the caption reads caleb is 3
he's already claiming I left his tears
tumblr he calls his ben shapiro cup and
wanted me to send this picture to you
hashtag left his tears somewhere hashtag
your youngest fan that is an
extraordinarily cute child yeah well
done there thanks for the pick big hello
to Caleb Zion also if you haven't seen
the verdict podcast with Ted Cruz you do
need to check it out my very best friend
in the whole wide world Michael Mills
and I'm being facetious because he's the
worst person I've ever met
co-host the show I'm their most recent
episode they had on AG bill bar here's a
bit of what that sounded like we are
seeing her
strong evidence of coordination and many
of these violent episodes fundamentally
what you have here is you have
demonstrators some of them go there with
the intent of demonstrating but you have
a group of provocateurs and agitators
sometimes a significant group they try
to convert those into violent activity
and they seem to be very well
coordinated when they show up already so
check that out wherever podcast I found
tried to ignore the fact that Knowles is
on the show and enjoy senator Cruz along
with AG bar also go subscribe we have a
reader's pasts let's send a buck a month
to get started so go check it out right
now become one of our members we have
like all-access lives where I hang out
with you and I sing weird songs and we
do weird voices and it's very odd but
people seem to like it go check it out
right now until you are calm slash
subscribe
you're listening to the largest fastest
boring conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
all righty so the cultural revolution as
I say continues a pace there's now push
to replace the star-spangled banner
because it's written by Francis Scott
Key there's a piece by Lindsey Parker
the editor-in-chief of Yahoo music
suggesting that we replace I am not
kidding you we replace the star-spangled
banner with imagine but the worst song
ever written in human history and by the
way maybe we should just do it we've
fallen further from god's grace every
day here in this country and I think
that if God has really decided to punish
us this way perhaps imagine is the final
shameful adoption of that which has
become our national credo a nation
without any sort of principle borders
religion concept of sin a vindictive
horrifying nation of people enacting
intolerable cruelty is like singing
imagine to them on each other and so
there's there's a push to get rid of the
national anthem also it's just it's all
stupid posturing at this point Mayor
Bill de Blasio wants to paint black
lives matter on the street outside Trump
Tower which is just idiotic pop
congratulations mayor de Blasio who
solves all the problems in New York City
including the massive spate of shootings
that has happened in your city over the
last 14 days because you've decided to
castrate the police so more dead people
but also paint on the sidewalk
to make fun of Trump you owned him you
owned him all those dead people they
feel really great about Mayor Bill
DeBlasio painting crap outside I love
that you're painting black lives matter
outside from tower while black people
get shot in New York really it's the
irony is is I think lost on very few
people really really amazing stuff and
Trump is so easily goaded he then
tweeted in response he said he
referenced de Blasio's a plan to quote
paint the fabled and beautiful Fifth
Avenue right in front of Trump Tower
slash Tiffany and then he went after
black lives matter and pointed out that
the black lives matter group is
incredibly radical which of course is
true but these sort of phone the
nation's are these super useful
I mean well even sort of minor
violations of our new Creed in America
have been have must be expunged so good
news they're changing Splash Mountain
splash around will now be the princess
in the frog do I really care about that
not really I can't lie princess in the
frog and if you ever go to like I'm big
Disneyland person we have annual passes
you ever go to like Mickey's magical map
the culmination
that of that hole at home that whole
show is a number from princess and frog
so it's a lot of fun you want to do that
fine it sounds this need to do that
that's cool
but the reason they are doing it is
because apparently Splash Mountain was
giving out like subtle racist messages
because it uses zippity-doo-dah
which comes from Song of the South which
is an actual racist cartoon but nobody
who has ever sung zippity-doo-dah for
the last 50 years is wherever the
origins of zippity-doo-dah
like no one I've been on splash around a
thousand times it has never occurred to
me it has anything to do with race at
all they're not even people on the ride
right it's Brer Rabbit in the and the
weird bear and all this like that okay
anyway they're changing that because
even the mildest ends of something bad
in history has to be expunged also the
Dixie Chicks are changing their name
they're no longer the Dixie Chicks now
they will be known as the chicks which
doesn't really seem to me to solve the
problem I feel like that's just
radically sexist shouldn't they be the
women's
be the the the the the brownout pronoun
of unspecified gender my chick chick
seems a little bit it seems a little bit
demeaning the checks so they're getting
rid of Dixie because apparently this
means that like if you if you ever say
Dixit so how like winn-dixie does
winn-dixie have to change its name if
you use the term Dixie which is like a
geographic region if you use that term
you have to get rid of it by the way was
anybody under the misimpression that the
Dixie Chicks were like Confederates I'm
just wondering so all of this seems very
stupid but the good news is at least we
can find humor in this stupidity so this
is the best story of the day Chaz is
falling apart guys it's falling apart
and it's falling apart in the most
hilarious possible way apparently people
are just leaving people are fleeing the
beautiful beautiful landscape of
democracy ridden Chaz may a block party
of joy where people just getting shot
can randomly they're just leaving this
peaceful preserve away from the
predations of American capitalism and
the brutality of America's racist cops
and they're fleeing this wonderful
utopia for the racist violence ridden
hell escape of the United States
so they've left the independent republic
of chaz and they are moving back into
the united states a statement from a
Twitter account that claims to be
associated with the protest zone said
only only a few people remain in our
beloved chop only a few people that's
the super super sad stuff by the way
mayor Jenny gherkin who had declared
this thing like democracy protests and
all this she had said that we're gonna
clean this thing out in the next few
weeks cuz it turns out people keep
getting shot in in Utopia thousands of
protesters occupied it and then
everybody left by the way a bunch of
business owners now suing the city
properly for not protecting their
property properly hip-hop artist and de
facto chopped warlord Raz Simone
acknowledged the protesters have drawn
attention from critics he says the
protesters of Chazz have targets on
their backs that is an issue a lot of
peaceful protesters are being harmed so
it's sad that's where we're at in
America um you're not in America you're
in Chazz so that's on you dude if you're
the leader of jazz and people getting
shot in your territory I feel like
that's you my the best quote on this is
from a seattle community leader named
Andre Taylor he said it's over because
of the violence
I've told people here don't be focused
on the location chop is not a location
it's an idea
fruit chop has never been tried true
Chazz has never been tried it's an idea
guys sure the reality is people bleeding
out in the streets and like us trying to
farm by dumping topsoil on cardboard and
calling it a farm and a sitting out
there and and now shaming each other
doing malice struggle sessions about our
white privilege but really it's more an
idea than it was a reality true chop has
never been tried it's really good you
know chop really was the friends we made
along the way except the ones who are
dead those ones we don't remember them
but everybody else that was a friend it
was the journey chop was the journey not
the destination guys chop was the idea
it wasn't the reality indeed chop a sad
r.i.p too it's a chop we hope that it
will one day be resurrected in a newer
better form sort of like Venezuela
versus Q but probably it'll work out
exactly differently probably won't be it
it'll be great it'll be great
already well come back to later today
for two additional hours of content
otherwise try to have yourself a weekend
don't pass on an infection to anybody
try not to tear down a statue
accidentally try not to burn down the
country I keep encouraging people to do
this over the weekend then everybody
just ignores it and maybe I should maybe
I should go the other way maybe I should
just encourage people to do evil things
and then they'll ignore me
and do the right things because it seems
like my attempts to push people to be
better have failed dramatically sorry
about that it's on me guys it's on me I
accept my own white privilege that's
round Angelo I'd say we'll see you here
next week i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director pavel vide aus key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam
SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen